[موسيقى]
هذه الدبابه التي تم تطويرها عام 2013
ظهرت للمره الاولى في عام 2015 خلال عرض
عسكري بمناسبه الذكرى السبعين للنصر في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه الدبابه التي تم
التجربتها في سوريا طبقا لتقارير روسيه
مسلحه بمدفع من عيار 125 مليمتر وبمدى يصل
الى 12 كم
[موسيقى]
هذه الدبابه يمكنها اطلاق صواريخ موجهه
مضاده للدروع من طراز انذار او اسبرنتر
كما انها مسلحه بمدفع اخر من عيار 12.7
مليمتر وكذلك مدفع رشاش داخلي من عيار
7.62 ملم اما برج الدبابه فهو مزود
بمنظومه دفاع نشطه واجهزه استشعار تمكن
الطاقم من رصد التهديدات من اي صواريخ
مضاده للدبابات بل والتعامل معهم
[موسيقى]
الشركه المصنعه لهذه الدبابه تقول انها
مطليه بماده تجعلها خفيه عن اجهزه الرادار
ومنظومات الرؤيه الليليه الحراريه في حين
تتحدث تقارير روسيه عن استلام الجيش
الروسي لسبع دبابات من هذا الطراز بل
ودخول هذه الدبابات الى ارض المعارك
الدائره حاليا مع الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]